do you have nicknames for your crew uh
no I don't okay do you yeah what are
your nicknames for your crew one is
awful I've been calling her piss since
we were 12. I remember this because at
your book event she said hi what's her
real name Christina yeah I wouldn't yeah
it was amazing because she said hi I'm
Christina you probably know me as piss
so why do you call her kiss we were 12
and I accidentally said I was gonna say
Chris and I said piss instead and I was
like oh my God that's the funniest thing
I've ever heard and then I just called
her piss forever it's just right she
saved under my phone is pissed when my
parents are like I say oh Christina's
coming over they're like pissed I was
like yeah and everyone just knows her is
pissed it's awful I and she has two kids
now so I'm trying to stop calling her
piss but it's uh it's pretty it's stuck